as the Autumn rain drizzles Andre loads
his car with humanitarian supplies
he's now the only help getting through
to the front line villages in this part
of Kirsten region it's very dangerous
because artillery of Russian is very
stupid because he won't been anywhere
don't bombing on only soldiers it's all
over the place yes
oh
his journey takes him across flat open
roads fields of what should have been
watermelons and now the boggy terrain of
this conflict this is only possible when
the shelling stops
when he arrives into Channel villagers
quickly emerge to meet him the war here
is getting worse and so is the suffering
foreign what Andre hands out will be the
only supplies they get here until he can
get through to this place again
yesterday yesterday
for people like and four people were
killed in this Village on the street
the sea saw fighting here in the south
of Ukraine like everywhere else is
taking an enormous toll most people have
fled their homes left in Ruins creating
a huge Refugee crisis in the heart of
Europe
the Frontline towns and Villages along
the southern front have all been pounded
continuously by Russian Artillery here
nearly every building has been hit by
Russian shelling but Ukrainian forces
are telling us that they do now have
momentum in the fights for curse on but
for those caught in the crossfire this
conflict remains extremely destructive
at the center of the fighting is the
occupied city of keson where there are
signs the Kremlin may be losing the
Russian flag taken down from the
administrative building and checkpoints
abandoned overnight is it a sign of
retreat or an act of deception
private Yuri covers his face his family
is still trapped in occupied territory
he's confident Ukraine can and will win
but not without enormous sacrifice the
shelling actually has increased in the
past several days so the civilians are
struggling I spoke to like five people
from the village of zolta balka this
morning and it's been the hardest since
the beginning of War they say and it's
only like 15 kilometers away so the
troops are advancing but the battles are
as hard as they go and people are
suffering
but for all the progress the conditions
for civilians are becoming unbearable
Russia is targeting energy and water
infrastructure in a cruel escalation the
damage in many places too great to fix
before winter arrives it is the people
that are being made to suffer
Alex Rossi Sky News in the careson
region